[Musique]
ravi de vous retrouver sur france 24
c'est l'heure de votre journal de
l'afrique bienvenus la ville du cap aux
couleurs de l'ukraine l'opposition
sud-africaine affiche clairement son
soutien à kiev a contrario à pretoria la
une ces ménages moscou sont alliés les
explications dans une ase de caroline
dumay la tunisie suspendue aux lèvres du
fmi elle attend un accord de prêt
l'économie va mal les fonctionnaires
peinent à être payés est les pme ferme
reportage france 24 à suivre des prêches
pour sauver l'environnement c'est le
pari d'évêques kenyan une alternative
peu conventionnel mais qui a trouvé son
public vous le verrez anaérobie
accueillait cette semaine l'assemblée
des nations unies pour protéger la
nature
la mairie du cap séparé jeudi soir d'or
et de bleu les couleurs du drapeau
ukrainien ainsi en a décidé la lience
démocratique qui dirige la ville à un
pied-de-nez aussi à la haine c'est le
parti au pouvoir lui qui n'a pas voté la
résolution de l'onu condamnant la guerre
menée par la russie en ukraine pas
question de sermonner un ami de longue
date retour sur une fidélité sans faille
avec caroline dumay si l'opposition sud
africaine en tout cas l'alliance
démocratique au cap soutient le cren
contre la russie force est de constater
que l' insee au pouvoir à pretoria est
bien embarrassé embarrassée parce que
les sud africains sont liées aux russes
sur deux plans sur un plan historique et
sur un plan économique sur un plan
historique
les russes étaient les plus fidèles
alliés des sud africains dans la lutte
anti apartheid
les russes fournissait du matériel
militaire les russes entraîner les
troupes on sait par exemple que l'ancien
président thabo m'beki a étudié à moscou
mais les liens sont aussi sur un plan
économique l'afrique du sud fait partie
du fameux groupe des brics brésil russie
inde chine et afrique du sud ce sont des
partenaires commerciaux importants et
même financiers pretoria obtenu un prêt
de plus d'un milliard de dollars pour
lutter contre le coc vide à l'année
dernière
donc la situation est un petit peu
délicate il ya quelques jours le chargé
d'affaires de l'ambassade américaine
demandait à pretoria de clarifier sa
position il cite l ancien prix nobel de
la paix desmond toutou qui disait que
quand il y avait un agresseur et un
agressé si on ne prenait pas position
c'est qu'on prenait position pour
l'agresseur la balle est dans le camp du
président cyril ramaphosa
à l'afrique du sud ou le diffuseur
satellite multichoice emboîte le pas
l'union européenne il suspend à son tour
russia today 20 millions d'abonnés
africains seront privés la chaîne de
télévision russe est accusé notamment
par les européens de propagande et de
déformation des faits en pleine guerre
en ukraine
dakar rappelle kiev à l'ordre en cause
un appel à candidatures publié sur la
page facebook de l'ambassade d'ukraine
au sénégal ceux qui le souhaitaient
pouvaient se porter volontaires pour
rejoindre les rangs de l'armée
ukrainienne face aux troupes russes
trente six personnes auraient ainsi été
recrutés chez les autorités sénégalaises
je me rappelle non pas condamner à l'onu
la guerre menée par la russie à la
correspondance delinda
sénégal a été convoqué ce jeudi au
ministère des affaires étrangères du
sénégal suite à cet appel à candidatures
posté à mercredi sur la page facebook de
l'ambassade de l'ukraine au sénégal
visant à recruter des volontaires
étrangers particulièrement sénégalais
pour aller rejoindre les rangs de
l'armée ukrainienne après avoir vérifié
l'authenticité de cet appel à
candidatures nous renseigne le
communiqué publié par le ministère
sénégalais des affaires étrangères dakar
a notifié à kiev une note verbale de
protestation et à dénoncer cette
pratique qui selon lui constitue une
violation des accords de vienne sur les
relations diplomatiques le post facebook
a depuis été supprimée de la page de
l'ambassade d'ukraine au sénégal sur
demande des autorités sénégalaises qui
précise que le recrutement de
mercenaires de combattant ou de volonté
un strictement interdit sur le
territoire sénégalais est passible des
sanctions prévues à par la loi à dakar
montrer si sa posture de neutralité
depuis l'éclatement de ce conflit qui
oppose l'ukraine et la russie mercredi à
lors du vote de la résolution des
nations unies exigent que la russie
n'utilise pas la force contre l'ukraine
le sénégal a faisait partie de la
quinzaine de pays africains qui
s'étaient abstenus
l'impasse politique et la crise
économique la double peine pour la
tunisie la dette dépasse les 100% du pib
le pays à demander un nouveau prêt au
fmi le troisième en 10 ans même les
classes moyennes sont en difficulté
reportage france 24 signale il ya blaise
et âme dit les nids
après 10 ans de lutte pour maintenir son
entreprise à flot à catherine au centre
ouest du pays il ne reste à khaled qu'un
des coups il a entassé son matériel avec
la crise sanitaire il a dû fermer en
2020 son entreprise spécialisée dans la
peinture en bâtiment je te j'ai ramené
toutes mes machines ici parce que j'ai
dû quitter les locaux de mon entreprise
je ne pouvais plus payer le loyer il
existe près de 20me pme en tunisie près
de 12,9 pour cent d'entre elles ont dû
fermer temporairement ou définitivement
après la pandémie comme khaled beaucoup
n'ont pas eu d'être suffisante des
banques ou de l'état
on sait que ce n'est pas la priorité de
l'état avec la crise actuelle de
soutenir les entrepreneurs surtout dans
les régions les plus reculées c'est
impossible pour moi de vendre mon
matériel c'est près de dix ans de
travail j'ai toujours espoir d'une
relance un espoir qui est surtout un
rêve pour le moment
un rêve de relance dans un pays où la
crise économique empire elle touche
aussi le budget des ménages même de
classe moyenne comme pour cette mère de
famille qui fait plus attention là j'ai
une application et à chaque forget de
dépenses quelque chose alors je mets
toutes mes dépenses
on a envie de d'économiser parce que
sinon on peut pas y arriver autrement
l'inflation dans le pays est supérieure
à 6% actuellement nous suivons est là à
l'épicerie du quartier où elle préfère
aller pourrait éviter les tentations des
grandes surfaces mais les prix restent
élevés
le plateau à
l'arrière la csn sénart 5 déjà ça
faisait marsac c'était cher le pays est
en pleine négociation avec le fonds
monétaire international pour obtenir un
nouveau prêt une course contre la montre
le temps joue contre tout le monde dans
la situation actuelle
parce que la situation des entreprises
publiques la situation des entreprises
privées de secteurs entiers de
l'économie
s'ils ne se remettent pas au travail et
bien leur situation continue de se
dégrader aujourd'hui la tunisie a besoin
de près de 6 milliards d'euros pour ses
dépenses de l'année 2022
la justice algérienne a condamné en
appel est khaled rare ni à six mois de
prison avec sursis une peine réduite il
avait écopé de deux ans en 2020 le
journaliste était poursuivi pour
incitation attroupement non armés alors
qu'ils couvraient les manifestations du
frac condamnation en appel aussi pour un
autre journaliste le marocain omar radi
six ans de prison ferme
confirmation de la peine prononcée en
première instance une double affaire
d'espionnage et de viol le reporter est
connu pour ses critiques envers les
autorités reporters sans frontières
appelle à sa libération immédiate
le maroc qui jamais depuis
1981 n'avait été aussi sec une
sécheresse qui affecte l'agriculture et
c'est tout le monde rural qui en paient
les pots cassés d'autant que les prix ne
cessent de grimper le gouvernement a dû
mettre la main à la poche reportage dans
la région de settat signée jean marie
lemaire
le maroc fait face à la pire sécheresse
depuis 40 ans et les répercussions
économiques risquent d'être ressentie
dans tout le royaume les petits
agriculteurs en sont les premières
victimes
nous souffrons beaucoup de la sécheresse
donc je rien à manger nous n'avons pas
d'eau ou le maire elle n'est pas
acheminée nous demandons des subventions
que nous n'avons toujours pas reçu
les grands agriculteurs plus de
ressources pour arroser laurent r
contrairement à nous les petits
agriculteurs
petites ou grandes exploitations les
difficultés et les risques d'arrêt de la
production sont bien réelles mais à des
échelles différentes
les manifestants
agriculteurs éleveurs sur les terres
familiales depuis trois générations
nasser est principalement producteurs
laitiers il sait déjà que les récoltes
pour nourrir ses bêtes ne seront pas
suffisantes
malgré l'utilisation d'un système
d'irrigation
sophistiqué mais coûteux qui ne sert
habituellement que d'arrosage d'appoint
sa crainte une nappe phréatique qui sera
rapidement épuisé je récolte ce que je
te raconte l'année dernière de mettre en
panne ces deux matières vertes par
hectare cette année je veux faire 5
tonnes si maintenant on vit sur les
stocks de l'année passée qui était une
bonne année mais dans les prochains
jours arrêt comment on va faire une
annonce faite par le gouvernement pour
des aides sur une période de six mois
semble insuffisante pour ce producteur
laitier cette aide de 6 mois soit
possible il faut trouver une autre
solution par exemple les éleveurs l'été
on demande d'augmentation du litre de
lait le ministère ne veut pas entendre
parler d'augmentations nous aurons
augmenté d'un tir ami l'aurait pas sorti
un centime de reprocher le programme de
lutte contre la sécheresse s'élève à 10
milliards de dirhams avec des priorités
comme le sauvetage du bétail
l'équipement de points d'eau
l'accélération de la mise en oeuvre de
l'assurance sécheresse pour les
agriculteurs qu'ils allègement de leurs
charges financières avec le report des
remboursements à l'année prochaine nous
n'avons pas connu une telle situation
depuis le début des années 80 le déficit
est de 80% rapport à l'année précédente
ça nous tenait le dos de remplissage des
barrages ne dépassent pas les 7%
les agriculteurs scrutent le ciel en
espérant encore la venue des pluies
pourvu qu'elle ne soit pas trop tardive
et abondante on risque de détruire le
peu de leur récolte la sécheresse qui
n'a pas non plus épargné le kenya cette
année le pays accueillait cette semaine
l'assemblée des nations unies dédiée à
l'environnement les 175 pays présents à
nairobi ont adopté un traité ambitieux
mettre fin à la pollution au plastique
c'est le première accord mondial en la
matière le texte devrait entrer en
vigueur d'ici 2024 le kenya lui aussi
ardemment contre la déforestation au sud
la région de kilifi par exemple a perdu
16% de ses forêts en 20 ans pour
sensibiliser les habitants une ong mise
sur la religion reportage de bastien
renouil et caroline qui me
comme chaque dimanche les fidèles se
réunissent dans cette église pour une
messe un peu particulière
quand on a beau ton lorsque dieu a créé
l'homme et lui a dit de prendre soin de
l'environnement yamoun un sermon
atypique pour ce pasteur défenseurs de
l'environnement
pour sensibiliser sa communauté il a
décidé d'utiliser la bible iphone pour
l'art
les gens sont très réceptives est fait
non parce que ça vous transmettons la
parole de dieu one day one of god save
about a donc six et warhol de dieu de
faire quelque chose c'est dieu lui-même
il leur donne
contrairement à ce que disent les
scientifiques hounsa mal à pipo en
l'espace de vingt ans la région de
kilifi a perdu 16% de sa couverture
forestière
les agriculteurs utilisent rarement des
techniques respectueuses de
l'environnement et des friches de plus
en plus d'arbres pour faire pousser
leurs cultures après la messe lo ng du
pasteur enseigne aux paysans comment
augmenter le rendement de leur culture
de manière durable
ça m'a aidé cette année je n'ai pas
cultiver une grande parcelle de terre et
des tic j'ai commencé à utiliser les
techniques enseignées par le pasteur
j'ai un roman bien plus important
dans la région de plus en plus
d'organisations protège l'environnement
celle ci préfère une approche plus
conventionnel contrairement à la
religion la science permet selon son
fondateur de n'exclure personne
lorsque l'on parle de multi v selon la
parole de dieu mais que l'on utilise la
religion fait à lesquin il faut
s'assurer que le projet et aux
enveloppes toutes les religions
représentés dans la communauté est
connue n'était mais selon lui l'
approche religieuse peut être
complémentaire si elle est bien menée
l'important reste en d'atteindre le but
nationale d'une couverture forestière de
10% du territoire d'ici 2030
avant de refermer cette édition cette
information provenance du mali où une
base militaire a été attaqué dans le
centre du pays au moins 27 soldats sont
morts 32 autres ont été blessés on n'a
pas encore de plus de détails quant aux
circonstances de cette attaque elle
intervient après deux trois semaines
après la fin de l'opération barkan
l'opération française dans pays on y
reviendra bien sûr dans notre prochaine
édition c'est à
22h45 à 10 il a cessé rhinebeck qui
prend la suite pour la suite de paris
direct reste avec nous
[Musique]
contre la transmission pensons aération
quand on parle quand on rit et même
quand on respire des microgouttelettes
invisibles à l'oeil nu restent en
suspension dans l'air et peuvent
transmettre le virus du coville 19 c'est
pourquoi il est important d'aérer 10
minutes toutes les heures pour les faire
disparaître
même vacciné continuons à appliquer les
gestes barrière ceci est un message du
ministère chargé de la santé et de santé
publique france